[Musique]
ben non
mecheri toute l'équipe est là et
regarder parce qu'on a excuse moi tu as
des arts magiques
le presque j'aime bien j'adore les
bombers sont magnifiques mais je sais
pas vous être inconnu retour autrement
tu vas dégagée dans sa moitié de
bouteilles ans est la mienne je suis que
c'est ma bouteille m'a donné
immédiatement
non tu la prends toi tu la prends moi
même l'ouvrir sans retard et à l'ouvrir
il va pas les all we en parlant de
dégager oui un peu oublier une promesse
que mon ami effet il ya trois-quatre
jours que j'attendrais deux minutes
parce qu'on n'est pas la bibliothèque
juste petit oui alors là c'est même moi
j'ai à peine troublée chauffe et je me
suis entraîné j'ai bossé comme un fou
vous l'a dit mais les mais si je peux
animée
[Musique]